where it says lizanne that's a typo for
st. Louis and what says Monday 13th July
that's a typo for Saturday the 26th of
September this is my daughter that thing
on her head is called many things but we
call them our family of Snuffy and when
she got a bit older she decided that I
needed a smurfy and a little bit later
she made me a second one as well because
now I work with process calculate so
there they are in case you can't see
them
and the reason I'm waving this around at
you is to make the point that many
people think of varying computing as
hard it's this big tough thing no theory
is you're soft cuddly friend I'm told
what somebody what said oh well we call
that monads it was a mistake we should
have called them warm fuzzy things so
the this is a talk about a way of
building domain-specific languages and I
hope you'll take away from the talk any
way that you could go about building
domain-specific languages that you may
find useful but the other takeaway from
the talk is theory is your warm fuzzy
friend theory is not something that
makes things difficult I think was our
boss Mao who said if you have a
mathematical approach to something and
you do not use it is it's as if you were
trying to find something in the dark and
you did not use a candle to light your
way so theory is a tool that will help
things out for you and it's warm and
fuzzy and cuddly
so the question I'm going to be looking
at is how do you integrate a
domain-specific language with a host
language and I'm going to base the
solution on two old ideas quotation
which goes back to Lisp in the 1960s and
normalization which goes back even
further to the work of Ganson in 1935
and this is some of you will have heard
me talk about jensen in my talk
yesterday and this is gansan on my chest
here that's the only t-shirt a curry I'm
going to do by the way another lesson
you can take aways this what is a
functional language it's a
domain-specific language for
implementing other domain-specific
languages that's really what functional
languages excel at so I'm going to show
you a particular approach to integrating
SQL into a host language and they'll say
a bit at the end about how we also used
it so I'm going to integrate SQL into
f-sharp and they'll say a bit at the end
about how we also used it to take a
domain-specific language for doing
signal processing called feldspar
developed at Chalmers in your table
array in Sweden and integrated that into
Haskell so I'll give you two examples
but mostly focus on the first example
and there's a paper you can go look
papers you can go look up and of course
you can ask me questions so let's get
started who loves SQL a few people okay
I'm going to assume that we want to talk
to SQL people often do and we want to
make this integrated as seamlessly into
our host language as we can so here's a
little bit of SQL so we've got a tiny
database of people and we're finding all
the people who are older than Alex so
that's Burt Cora and Edna sorry all the
people who are younger than Alex
so we want to integrate this into our
host language so how do we do this well
we can take the database and view it as
data so in this case we've just got one
table called people so we've got a
record with one entry called people and
then we've got a bunch of rows in our
database so we turn that into a list and
each row has two columns name and age so
each record has a name field and an age
fields we've just taken our database and
turned it into data and now we can write
a little program against that data to
execute the data so this is actually
very close in structure to the SQL that
we had so that says we're going to
return the name and age fields of V and
U and V are both going to range over the
people table and when you name is Alex
that VH must be less than u age so
that's why we're finding all people
younger than Alex and this is exactly
the same thing for u and DV people for V
and DB people if you name is Alex and B
age is less than u age then return the
name and age fields it gives the exact
same answer so they're done perfect
anything wrong with this boy what a
quiet Bunch so we're all done right this
is a perfect solution yes
it's a bit inefficient right normally we
would expect this to run in about linear
time if you do the indexing properly but
this was going to do two loops over the
table so it's going to take quadratic
time rather than linear time so it's
just a lot less efficient than the
actual SQL code so that's a wee bit of a
problem any other problems okay so this
is more imperative than declarative
actually it's so what to do rather than
what you want was the way it was put
actually no because the structure of
this exactly matches the declarative
structure so I'm going to say that it's
the same structure as the SQL so I don't
think that's too much of a problem
I think the efficiency is a problem yes
there's a disparity between the data and
the query language well what do you mean
by that
there's an impedance mismatch so our
goal here is to reduce this impedance
mismatch right to be able to access the
data completely okay but there is
another problem here that nobody's
mentioned yet but I'm sure many of you
have already thought of right this table
has six lines okay reading this into
memory and storing it as six lines
that's not a problem of course often
databases have terabytes of data I'm
doing this cuz there's a bright light
they're shining on the screen
right sometimes it says six lines you
have terabytes and terabytes of data and
reading all that in to the main memory
would not be feasible so it takes way
too much space and it takes to a too
much time other than that it's perfect
so where do we may do about it what
we're going to do is write some stuff in
blue and what I've done by writing stuff
in blue is you see the blue things the
blue term is surrounded by these less
than at sign and at sign greater sign
that's how you do quotation in F sharp
so this is no longer a term it's a data
structure it's a data structure that
represents the term and the type of a
data structure that represents a term is
expert of the type of the term so DB
here is a people record which then
contains lists of name of records with
name and age fields and so the type of
this thing which returns a table like
that is an expert of records of those
kinds of Lists so we just write expert
of some type to mean a data structure in
memory representing the parse tree of a
term that returns the value of that type
and this is very standard this is just
called quotation how many people are
completely asleep because they're very
familiar with quotation okay only about
half of you are admitting to being very
familiar with quotation I suspect many
more of you are familiar with it but if
you're not familiar with quotation
congratulations you've just met
quotation it's an old technique going
back at least as far as Lisp and it's
extremely useful so it's a very standard
technique we can represent terms of our
language as data in our language
and now the point is we've represented
this as a term so we have a proce
processor that deals with that and it's
called run so run takes in this data
structure and then I already mentioned
this looks a lot like the SQL so it can
convert it directly to the SQL now in
general for every program we write it
might be a bit harder to convert to SQL
so that's the next thing we're going to
talk about but here it's very easy and
straightforward to compute convert to
SQL so the steps that run takes is it's
going to simplify the quoted expression
in this case the only simplification
that's needed is you notice so these
bits written in black with a percent in
front of them are anti quotation and
that just means okay there must be a
term an expert term of the appropriate
type that goes in there and DB is a term
of type X / DB and that database
primitive for a naive user it means
that's the whole database read in as
data but what we're actually going to do
is just generate SQL that doesn't need
to read in the whole database so we have
a database primitive that gets spliced
in in those two parts so database and
run are the two primitives that we've
introduced here everything else the for
and if and yield happen to already be
parts of F sharp so we simplify the
quoted expression we then translate that
quoted expression a query to SQL we
execute the SQL and then we translate
the answer back to the host language
remember I said if you took the whole
database and read it in that would be
too expensive but the answers are
usually much smaller so we're going to
assume that we can just on translate
those at once if you wanted to you could
add a streaming but I won't talk about
that and then we get a theorem warm
fuzzy feelings
that each run generates a query if the
answer type is flat just meaning it's a
table just meaning it's a list of
records of scalars where scaler is an
basic type such as integer or string so
that's exactly what you can store in SQL
so just as the answers of a type that
SQL can represent we're going to
translate to SQL that seems a reasonable
constraint we only do permitted
operations so for instance most versions
of SQL don't implement recursion so we
better not use recursion and we only
refer to one database remember I spliced
in DB twice here it was the same
database both times we ever referred to
two different databases and you'd have a
query across two different databases and
that would be hard to change translate
into a single SQL query so it's a
reasonable constraints and those are
once we impose you might actually want a
type system that imposes all these we
want and that's very easy to do but we
wanted to run in standard f-sharp so we
just assumed that users can check these
and we check it at runtime and it's easy
to check now I just showed you the
technique applied in F sharp but it's
all you need is some form of quotation
it turns out lots of languages supply
this so Scala is an example of the
language that's applies to see here's
the same thing
this is naive query in Scala it's very
similar and here's the same thing using
this technique in Scala of writing bits
in blue the interesting thing in Scala
is there are no quote marks or anti
quote marks here the way Scala does it
is with type inference and this type
that I was calling X because it's called
X by n F sharp is called wrap in Scala
there's something called lightweight
modular staging in Scala that gives you
a library that does all this and in fact
there's an interesting question is it
better to have explicit quote marks or
to let the type system do the inference
I think that's still open okay so that
was a very simple query let me show you
some
more interesting queries so the most
obvious thing to be able to do is to be
able to abstract over values so here's a
little query that takes in two numbers a
and B that returns all peoples whose age
is less than greater than or equal to a
and less than B so if we run range over
30 and 40 this will give us all our 30
something's and this will just translate
into this query very straightforwardly
so all you need to do is substitute 30
and 40 for a and B and then that looks
almost exactly like the SQL below that's
fairly straightforward so fun by the way
is the keyword for introducing a
function so it's just as a function that
takes two arguments a and B and then
returns the value which in this case is
a table of names on the row to the right
of the arrow and fun is of course the
keyword in a sharp that stands for
lambda so let's do something more
interesting pretty much every system for
integrating SQL into a programming
language can do that this one you find
much more rarely satisfies it's going to
take a predicate that is a function from
int to bool and return a table of names
so now we have a function that takes a
function as an argument what's called a
higher-order function so now we take
this function of X that returns true if
X is bigger than 30 and less than 40 so
this should turn into the same query as
before and it does and how does it do
this well we take one argument P which
is bound to this function here and then
P gets applied to age so when we apply P
to H then X gets replaced by WH in both
places and that turns into this query
so just by simplifying by normalizing
the query we can turn it into something
that could be SQL does this always work
you ask yes we have a thing
I'll explain why that holds later and
then here's the really interesting thing
to do pretty much every web service in
the world is just something that has a
front-end you type some stuff into it it
turns it into a data structure that
represents a query you then turn that
into an actual SQL query executed
against the database and present the
result that's pretty much every web
interface in the world
so we it's very interesting to be able
to take data structures that represent
queries and turn them into queries and
in this case it's very easy to do so
here's a very simple thing I'm gonna
have a data structure with three things
above and an integer below and an
integer or and and two more predicates
so this data structure is called
predicates so it's a little tree that
represents a query and it's easy to run
over it so apologies if you're not
familiar with f-sharp but if you are
this will be straightforward if you know
most functional languages it should be
straightforward so we just look at the
data structure T we've been given and if
it's an above of a we turn that into the
predicate the given X returns whether
lift of a whether X is greater than or
equal to lift of a or whether lift of a
is less than or equal that
and what's this lift thing well remember
a is going to be an integer and what we
need to splice in here is an expert of
integer so lift just turns an integer
into the quoted term that represents
that integer and similarly with below
and then and just takes X and applies
the translation of the predicate key and
the predicate u2 acts and returns true
if they're both true so now we have
something that given a data structure
returns a predicate and we can use our
previous satisfies function to apply
that so we could do run of satisfies of
P and we get the same queries before
notice right this is all straightforward
and really easy the only thing wrong
with it is it's insanely inefficient
right because what does pee at the end
of above of 30 and below 40 reduce to
well if you work it all through you get
that structure on the top and then you
have to normalize it a bit to get the
structure on the bottom so it's a fair
bit of work to do this but the
normalizer does it and notice we only do
this once per query going out to SQL and
getting the answer to a query is
generally pretty expensive so the fact
that we need to do this extra work is
literally down in the noise and I will
show you some tables later that confirm
that notice that to generate the query
we used recursion right of course we
just recursively walk over this
predicate datatype it's a very natural
and easy thing to do but remember I told
you oh you can't have recursion because
that's not in SQL but that's okay that
just means slip blue bits can't use
recursion here we have recursion in the
black bits so it's fine so that's all
there is to it okay in 20 minutes I have
now shown you how to take a relatively
hard problem how to integrate SQL with
your host language and make it really
easy so let's just explore a little bit
about why that worked and what's
interesting about it now if you're
familiar with domain-specific languages
you'll have seen other ways of doing
this but they look slightly different
from what I've shown you so predicate
for us have the type on the top right it
takes it returns an expert of int Abul
many systems do it a bit differently
they take an expert event to an expert
of bool and that's kind of useful
because remember this insane
normalization stuff I talked about we're
between you get this structure that
nobody in their right mind would write
down and then you simplify it so this
just generates that directly the
language generates the structure you
want without you needing to simplify
that's clearly a good thing right but it
turns out it has limits it does work
very well
in this case so the way most people
would write it is the way on the bottom
the way I've done it is the way on the
top and it's a trade-off right you could
do it either way but most people always
do it the way on the bottom so the new
thing I'm telling you here is hey you
can do the thing on the top and
sometimes that will be simpler and why
do we want to do the thing on the top
well if you look at how satisfies
changes so on the top is the way we
wrote satisfies if you're using the
other style remember P now takes an
expert event to an expert will so
instead of having an expert of interval
two names what we would need is
something that takes an expert event to
expert bool and then returns an expert
names and here's what you do and notice
this has something interesting in it it
has P that needs to be applied to W dot
age where W is found in the surrounding
quotation and then this builds a
structure where the W is properly bound
so that's okay there are complicated
tight systems that will guarantee that
this is okay so meta
o camel is a language that has a
suitable type system for doing this it
turns out that F sharp is not so if you
type this bottom expression into F sharp
you get an error message which
translates roughly as what are you crazy
you've got a W here that I don't know
where it's bound it turns out after you
build the whole thing it is properly
bound but it can't tell that using its
simple type system so in our case to use
standard F sharp we're forced to use the
technique on the top so this is why it's
important to understand both techniques
are available sometimes only the one on
the top works now it was so standard to
use this technique on the bottom that I
just assumed we're doing it the same way
everybody else does we're doing what the
people on the bottom do and then I
thought wait we'll wait no no we're not
and here's to me at the exact moment
when I realized that
this is actually a recreation and that
my daughter who sewed me the lambda is
the one who took the photo that is
edinburgh castle in the background and
this is really where I was at the moment
that I had this inside I was cycling
through the links with edinburgh castle
next to me when I suddenly realized Oh
what we're doing is not what everybody
else is doing
okay I've explained the difference to
you and there's an easy way to summer oh
let's see I'll come back to that in a
minute there's an easy way to summarise
the difference we're using order call
closed quotations that is no free
variables that get bound somewhere else
the other techniques needs what are
called open quotations that is you do
have a free variable in this case the W
and W dot H that gets bound somewhere
else and the other way to think about
that is we use quotations of functions
whereas everybody else uses functions of
quotations so both techniques are useful
and the point is to take you where you
can choose among the techniques and if
you have a language that just has closed
quotation like f-sharp that's a good
reason for choosing the first technique
now remember I said so this other
technique is sometimes called EDS ELLs
embedded dsls and instead of an expert
ATP as we try to use an expert of a to
expert V similarly except an expert of a
times B you'd use an expert of a times
expert B and that all works out
reasonably well and the system will
normalize things for you
but if you need a some type something
that's either an A or a B then you can't
use that trick because here an expert of
a plus B this choice between a and B is
made in the quoted term so that is it's
made in your target language but here
this plus is now in black rather than in
blue so the choice between these has to
be made in the host language and we
don't know at query generation time
which of these two we've got so this
does not work so well there are very
fancy tricks that can make it work but
it does not work as easily so that's
another reason why you might prefer the
approach to the eds l approach and then
the other thing I want to talk about is
why this works and it works of course
because of theory and you would have
heard me talking some of you will have
heard me talking yesterday about the
history of programming languages and in
particular the work that gets and did in
developing logic and in particular
improving this sub formula principle
that says that if you have a proof that
the only things that you need to write
down that proof are the hypotheses and
the conclusion and the in between all
the formulas that will appear will be
sub formulas that is parts of your
hypothesis and your conclusion so he
expressed that by saying perhaps we may
express the essential properties of such
a normal proof by saying it is not
roundabout no concepts enter into the
proof than those contained in its final
result and their use was therefore
essential to the achievement of that
results this is a nice property of logic
in particular let him show the
consistency of the systems he was
working with but for us it's really
useful because remember let's go back
here
right this is involving functions in
tubule functions and this is actually a
function that takes an integral function
as an argument so we have a function of
functions SQL doesn't support that right
all SQL supports is tables that is lists
of records of scalars not functions so
how do we know it's okay to stick a
function in the middle point here the
answer is exactly the sub formula
property because the sub formula
property says look if all of your
hypotheses in this case that's the free
variables that is and these are going to
be bound to tables in the database so if
all your tables in the database do not
involve functions and they don't write
they're just lists of records of scalars
and our result is a table that's a list
of records of scalars so we're
guaranteed to be able to simplify it
down to get rid of all the functions so
we know that any functions that we use
as long as they don't appear as
hypotheses as free variables or as the
result we will get rid of them and the
same would apply to products and to sums
and the normalization rules that we use
are these here so they fit in one slide
this is all online class you can
download this and the top rule is the
main rule used by Jensen the it's called
the beta rule of lambda calculus and it
just says what we did right if you've
got a function from X to N and you apply
to M just substitute M for X everywhere
and similarly if you've got a record l
equals M 0 or more times and you select
out the LF component well that's just
the LS component that you bounce so
those are very standard rules the others
are very standard rules actually the the
next two rules are what are called the
Monad laws but sorry I I pronounced that
wrongly let me say it again the warm
fuzzy thing laws
but having these laws is very helpful
because this is what guides doing your
normalization and then thanks to get
sims old result which we just adopt
slightly we're guaranteed that this
process terminates and gives you a
simplified term that if all your free
variables are tables and the result is a
table doesn't contain any functions that
you can't represent so we've applied
this in several different ways right to
eliminate higher-order functions I
showed you an example of that you can
also use it to eliminate nested
intermediate data I've not shown you
that you could also use it to fuse
intermediate or arrays I'm not going to
show you that at all and we've used
these in our implementations of SQL and
felspar but the point is this is a great
guiding principle and furthermore but
actually do two different techniques for
doing things QD s l's and DDS cells and
it works for both of them so the sub
formula principle is a great guiding
principle for designing dsls and it
basically says you can use any feature
you like in the host language such as
higher order functions or nesting and as
long as it doesn't appear in the free
variables or the result which in our
case it doesn't because the free
variables are all tables and the result
is a table then it will always simplify
away so it's a promise that you can get
use any feature you like of your host
language and you will be able to
simplify it away now that doesn't always
apply right when can come up with
situations where it doesn't apply but in
a wide variety of situations you can
make that work and you can use the sub
formula principle and this existing body
of theory as a guide to doing things as
a guide to writing down your normalizer
so the basic interface that I showed you
already existed in F sharp this idea of
saying we will treat queries as
quotations already exist in F sharp
indeed exist throughout the dotnet
framework as something called link
language integrated query and that's a
basic idea there so there were already
implementations of this idea in both the
2-0 and 3-0 versions of F sharp and on
the left here I've written down the
various queries so the first box are the
ones we actually saw and if I had an
hour and a half to talk to you I would
also explain the queries at the bottom
but this one for these two for instance
are about doing nesting using nested
data and these are about implementing X
query in SQL using the same technique
that I showed for the satisfies try to
get with that PT 0 and PT 1 so here's
the interesting thing notice that some
things work in F sharp to O and some
things work in F sharp 3 O and
relatively few things work in both so
what this means is f sharp 2 and F strep
through I'll use various ad hoc
techniques to massage the quoted term
they were given into SQL and sometimes
these techniques worked and sometimes
they didn't work and sometimes in this
case here this was with a nested query
it worked but it didn't give you just
one query it gave you a number of
queries proportional to the amount of
data you have that's called a query
avalanche which is why there's an AV
next to it so it worked but it was very
inefficient we have a theorem that says
it always works but to make this work of
course we have to normalize the term so
you remember I told you look you can
normalize the term and yes it will take
some time but it's a tiny amount of time
compared to the query I said it's
literally down in the noise and here's
the proof of that the normalization
time is in the column on the right and
just next to it is the actual runtime
that we had including query and you can
see the normalization time is a
relatively small part notice also by the
way that we didn't write a very
efficient normalizer we could have
written to normalize if it ran faster if
we put more effort into it so even with
an inefficient simple normalizer the
time is small compared to the query time
so there are two important takeaways
from the table right one is that this
works the normalization time doesn't
matter and the other is existing systems
really do get this wrong and using
normalization as a guide is very
important so any of you if you're doing
a DSL for SQL or anything else I would
urge you to think what are the relevant
normalization rules can I apply against
and sub formula property that's a handy
bit of theory that lets you structure
your creation of a domain-specific
language and I mentioned feldspar so
this is the only time on my show
feldspar and the only point here is that
Dan this does not list a separate
normalization times but again the point
is that the times that we got are very
comparable to the times for the old EDS
l version of feldspar so in other words
we can apply the technique and it works
reasonably well Pablo Picasso is famous
for saying good artists copy great
artists steal
actually he didn't say it apparently
Steve Jobs said that Pablo Picasso said
it so this a DSL technique that I talk
about is great because it lets you steal
the type system of the host language for
your target DSL and it lets you steal
some of the syntax of your host language
for the DSL some things like
conditionals get a bit difficult QD s
l's let you steal the types again let
you steal all the syntax and then if you
implement one normalizer you can use
that across all your different dsls for
the same language because you're just
normalizing your host language so as
long as your host language is the same
you can use the same normalizer the
weakness of this by the way is
implementing the normalize of the first
time is a fair bit of work so what we'd
hope is to provide libraries for people
and we're looking at doing that for
Haskell now okay everything old is new
again how do you go about integrating a
domain-specific language with a host
language just use the old ideas of
quotation and normalization and here's
the reference slide I didn't do this
work all on my own there are other
people who have contributed to the work
there are the relevant papers for those
of you who saw my paper my talk on
propositions as types yesterday I did
forget to mention that propositions as
types is written out as a paper you can
just download it from my website and it
will appear in kakum in December of this
year and also the library that I showed
you for F sharp is publicly available on
the website there and as part of the
effort sharp ecosystem now warm fuzzy
feelings to all of you thank you very
much
okay there's time for a few questions
yes let's point gap I want to go retro
for citations instead of citing McCarthy
I could cite girdle and of course
rotations a much older ideas well Quine
for instance wrote a lot about quotation
yes sar their other oh very good
question right what about the other
features in SQL like sorting or group by
and so on are there good normalization
rules for those that's actually open
research work so we're looking at that
question
there's a fellow named Torsten roost
who's done a lot of work in this area so
if you look at posting Luthor you will
see his solutions to normalization rules
for those features yes
right so the question is okay in the
case of SQL it does not support
higher-order functions by the way for
feldspar target language with C we're
doing very simple C where again we did
not want to support higher-order
functions but you might have a target
languages does support higher-order
functions is the technique still valid
then yes it is and in that case you
might have a result that still has
higher-order functions in it so your
normalization would not get rid of all
of them another question that you might
ask which is related is waggonette this
is always getting rid of all your
higher-order functions where it can
maybe you don't want to do that all the
time and indeed you might want some
control over where you normalize and
where you don't normalize and in the
papers we talked a little bit about how
you might give such control yes
okay so the question is well f-sharp is
an eager language a strict language and
Haskell is a lazy language does that
make any difference um in fact the rules
that I showed you that we use for
f-sharp
were the lazy rules to call-by-name
rules which lose sharing so if you look
at this paper here everything old is new
again we talked about how you do
reduction rules that do not lose sharing
and as you pointed out implicitly the
fact that we could use this technique
both for F sharp and for Haskell shows
that it works for both lazy and strict
languages good question thank you yes
would it be possible to partially
evaluate the normalization at compile
time in fact what I've called
normalization other people would call
partial evaluation so it is essentially
a partial evaluation technique yes
yes so the question is is there a
relationship between normalization and
the Y Combinator and we can take this
offline if you want but my first answer
would be no yes in the back what happens
if you good question what happens if you
use a function in the host language
that's not supported in the target
language so indeed that's a weakness of
this technique which is we do not
compile we do not detect this at
type-checking time some other systems
like EDS ELLs do check this find this
out at type-checking time
Shaya Najd who's the fellow in the
middle there looking a bit like a
criminal is working on a tool now that
will use template haskell to do all the
checking for you at type-checking time
but at runtime if there's an unpermitted
constant we find that out and we report
an error at runtime so we do report an
error at runtime but we don't that where
runtime means target code generation
time but we don't report it when you
compile up a host language you just have
to look for such things and our claim is
it's not too hard to spot them I see
several other great questions but we're
past 10 50 which is why I should stop
look if anybody else has a question
please come up and talk to me thank you
very much